on campaign check we're examining claims
made on the election trail the
Conservatives have announced new rules
they say will make it easier to recruit
doctors and nurses from around the world
there's the promise from the health
secretary the NHS in England employs 1.2
million star from at least 212 countries
this is the top ten you can see that
India the Philippines and Ireland are
the biggest contributors after the UK
but there are six EU nations in here too
but even this global workforce isn't
enough to keep up with demand the most
recent figures show there are ninety six
thousand three hundred and forty eight
vacancies in the NHS that's one in 12
post unfilled now the Conservatives say
to make it easier for foreign nationals
to work in the NHS they will cut the
visa fee from the current 928 pounds
down to four hundred and sixty four
that's half overseas workers will still
have to pay four hundred pounds a year
to cover their own health care but will
be able to pay it through their wages
and applicants should get a decision
within two weeks now the major change
here is that after brexit for the first
time visa rules will also apply to EU
Nationals 66,000 currently work in the
NHS in England that's five and a half
percent of the total nine and a half
percent of doctors and six point four
percent of nurses they won't need a visa
now if they have settled status but for
new joiners from the EU getting
permission to work in the NHS will be
harder and more expensive than it is
today
the Conservatives say all of this will
be part of a new Australian style point
space system but there is no other
detail a major flaw according to health
experts it's not completely clear
whether or not today's announcement will
mean that it's easier than it is now to
get stuff in from outside the EU it
doesn't sound as if it will be easier to
get stuff in than it is now from within
the EU so it's that lack of detail
that's a major concern and then there's
the fact that it doesn't seem to have
applied to social care in terms of the
policy we've heard about today the
social care sector offers vital support
to the NHS one and a half million people
work in this area and 17% of them are
from overseas and there is no detail on
how they will access the UK in few
under a points-based system the NHS
already struggles to fill vacant posts
so anything that makes it easier to
recruit will be welcomed
but imposing barriers on EU Nationals
for the first time is a significant
concern and there's simply not enough
detail about the wider system to judge
whether this policy will ultimately help
or hinder